hey vsauce
michael here
[Music]
and here
michael here
hey vsauce
what is here
what is there
what
is there
what really exists
do waves exist or are there just things
that are wavy when does a piece of food
stop being a piece of food and become me
do chairs
exist
ontology is the philosophy of existence
and chairs are what philosophers call
ordinary objects
ordinary objects are the plain old
common sense things we deal with every
day
spoons buckets rocks stuff like that
their existence is as obvious as
possible but the more we try to
suss out where they are
the more sus
they become
first of all sure this could all be a
dream maybe we've all been hallucinating
chairs all these years or
this could be part of the simulated
reality pumped into our brains while our
bodies are harvested for energy
but underneath that skepticism there's a
deeper ontological question we need to
answer first
regardless of whether this spoon is made
of
real atoms or simulated atoms
is it really possible to be made of
something
take a look at these two things as we
all know two minus one
is two
there are two things here there's an
origami crane and a piece of paper
i'm just kidding of course there's just
one thing the crane and the paper are
the same
but watch this
where'd the crane go
if the paper and the crane were truly
identical they would share everything in
common but clearly they don't the paper
can survive being unfolded
and the crane cannot
also i made the crane but i didn't make
the paper and the paper was around
before the crane you know for two things
that are the same
they sure are different
this relationship is called constitution
paper constitutes the crane it's a
one-to-one relationship
but there's another kind of being made
of going on here too
this paper for example is made not of
one other thing but of sextillions of
things fundamental subatomic particles
electrons and quarks or strings or
physical and virtual fields this many to
one relationship is called composition
philosophers call whatever it is that
matter is ultimately composed of
symbols a simple is a thing that unlike
a piece of paper has no parts no
substructure not even a top or bottom
now it could be the case that there are
no symbols that there's just a
never-ending chain of smaller and
smaller substructure philosophers call
such a reality a gunky universe
if structure never ends in the other
direction and everything turns out to be
part of something bigger with no final
complete composite that is known as a
junkie universe
point is believing ordinary objects
exist and are made up of smaller things
is quite common it's called ontological
reductionism it's the position that
holes are nothing more than their parts
but our crane and our paper challenge
that notion it seems like being made of
some things
is different than just being those
things
let's agree on what it means to exist
let's say that for something to exist is
simply for there to be more than zero of
it so pegasus exists if we mean are
there any winged horses in works of
fiction and mythology and pegasus does
not exist if we mean are there any
physical flesh and blood winged horses
that evolved on earth through natural
selection okay so if we can agree on
that
then of course chairs exist there's this
one right here i can see it and i can
feel it and i can taste it yeah
oh yeah it's kind of
dry
a little bit salty
dry and salty are what we call
properties
properties tell us what things are like
for example this slice of cheese is
floppy
by noticing and sharing properties we
can let each other know what to expect
from things and we all more or less
agree on what things there are we give
names to stuff and if they catch on we
put them in dictionaries with the word
noun next to them
but are all of these nouns an inventory
of the universe or an inventory of
things we made
let me put it this way
do islands exist
well it's in the dictionary and a quick
look around confirms that there are more
than zero islands so yes islands exist
but what about
in cars
an in-car is a car that is in a garage
as a car leaves a garage an in-car
diminishes at the threshold until it
collapses into non-existence later an
extremely similar in-car may emerge at
the same threshold when the car returns
are there any cars in garages right now
well if so then in cars exist
but you might be thinking uh
that's not a thing you just made that up
and it's silly being in a garage is just
a property that a car can have
stop trying to make in-cars a thing
okay but first of all i didn't make it
up eli hirsch did and second of all if
you think in-cars aren't things
wait until you hear about islands
an in-car might just be a relation
between a car and a garage but an island
is just a relation between land and some
water now of course island might be a
more useful concept than in-car but does
that make islands objectively more real
than in cars
and what about troggs
a trog is an object whose parts are a
tree and whatever dog is nearest here's
a picture of one do you see the trog
this is its tree part and this is its
dog part
you might be thinking come on
how can that be a thing the tree and the
dog aren't even connected
well so what these two pieces of fabric
aren't connected and yet they are a
thing called a bikini now sure if we cut
down this tree and burn it for warmth we
don't feel the need to apologize to
what's left of the trog for destroying
its tree part
but maybe we should
what if some
extraterrestrials showed up and said
they thought dogs and trees composed
troggs
would they be wrong
could we convince them otherwise
ontological realists believe that we
could that there really is a mind
independent answer to the question what
is there people like theodore cider
believe that the universe has joints and
that we can cut up reality into
objective real things by finding them
ontological anti-realists
disagree their position is that what we
think there is is just one way to cut up
reality it's a good one for us and our
needs but it's not objectively more true
than any other
so
who's right
hmm
well if these blocks compose a tower
what do they compose now
just because we don't have a name for
this
doesn't necessarily mean i haven't
accidentally built something
does it
when do two or more things
compose something else
peter van inwagen calls this the special
composition question in material beings
he considers possible answers maybe
things compose something only when
they're in contact well that's a good
thought but it doesn't explain how a
bikini can be a thing or why two books
are still just two books when one is
stacked on top of the other
you know maybe a certain degree of
fixation is required or a melding
if a surgeon sewed us together and the
skin healed with no seam and we shared
the same blood supply
you know even then it would seem wrong
to say that we'd become some new kind of
animal there'd still just be me and you
but like stuck together
the philosophy of parts and holes is
called myriology and myriological
universalism is the belief that there is
an answer to the special composition
question and the answer is this
any assortment of stuff no matter how
strange or scattered across time and
space composes a thing
some pages compose these books but i
don't just have two books here oh no
there's also a third thing let's call it
a a took because its parts are two books
there is also something composed of
my left ear the northern third of every
brown trout in england and the eiffel
tower
just because it doesn't have a name and
no one's ever talked about it before
just shows a lack of interest on our
part to a universalist eliminating some
composites but not others is just too
arbitrary we may as well accept them all
eliminativism is any belief that accepts
some composites but eliminates others
peter van inwagen for example believes
that there are no
ordinary objects no chairs or shirts or
shoes right here there are just some
symbols atoms or whatever arranged shoe
wise there isn't something else here
called a shoe
but he thinks that because people
believe that they themselves exist and
he can't see how something could believe
it existed without existing in the first
place to even think that there must be
people he goes further though to argue
that all living things
exist while admitting he doesn't have
any knock-down arguments in their favor
he mentions that because symbols that
are part of a living organism maintain
the organism while shedding some members
and gaining others all while remaining
individuated from other organisms unlike
say waves of water at the moment of
collision
clearly
symbols in the act of a life must
compose something
that position is called organicism it's
been called the belief that people exist
but none of them wear clothes
myriological nihilism is less generous
it's the belief that there are no trogs
or in cars
or
dogs or trees because nothing ever
composes now the nihilist does not
believe that there is nothing here there
are lots of symbols
but that's it
now that might sound puzzling how can a
bunch of fundamental particles arranged
into atoms and molecules that are
arranged like this
not be a chair i mean that's just what a
chair is
well good question
let's call that deflationism the belief
that this is all silly and that all
these positions are just talking past
one another i mean they all agree on
what reality contains they all believe
that there are symbols here and that
those symbols are arranged into a chair
shape and since that's just what a chair
is
they all believe in chairs those who say
they don't are just being weird and
contrarian
deflationism has many supporters and it
truly is the heart of our issue today
but to address it we should first see
why it would be nice if all these parts
did not form a chair
let's begin with over
determination if chairs really do exist
shouldn't they be able to interact with
us
the thing is though everything this
alleged chair can do can be described by
referencing the behavior of symbols here
and any other symbols that happen to
come along an account of the activities
of every atom in this room
leaves nothing for the chair to explain
composites are causally redundant
believing in chairs is like believing
that while yes the burning gas from my
stove completely describes why the water
in the pot boils
there's also a magical invisible
substance called boilo that comes out of
my stove and does the same thing as the
flame at the same time and if there was
no boil oh the flame would warm the
water just the same but there is boil-o
chairs are no more real than boil-o
composites over-determine what happens
in the world
they also lead to over-counting for more
on that let's say hello to this video's
sponsor
hi i'm michael stevens you may know me
from such films as lady gaga judas
parody key of awesome number 42 and the
emoji movie but today i'm here to talk
to you about the curiosity box this
season our subscribers will be receiving
many things including a shirt
celebrating the sherman line a kit to
find out what kind of
bacteria grows on you a puzzle that
celebrates the average color of neptune
and yes also
uranus and the first ever at-home
demonstration of impossible colors and
right now if you subscribe with code
bogo we'll also send you our entire
summer box completely free just pay
shipping how many things will you be
receiving for this one ridiculously low
price well you might think 15 8 things
plus seven things but don't forget that
you're also getting this entire
collection and this entire collection
that's 17 things
order now
that's a good deal
but the ontology seemed wrong if i count
some parts i shouldn't also count the
hole they compose
but if you believe in composite objects
you must right i mean after all the
composite exists so if this chair
contains say 100 sextillion atoms then
there are actually at least 100
sextillion and one things here all of
the atoms and also the chair
that seems wrong
but wait there's more
if i take a knife and scrape off a tiny
part of this chair
is it still a chair
i think most of us would say that yes it
is still a chair and it would still be a
chair even if i removed a tiny bit again
and again
a series of tiny innocuous removals is
called a psorides sequence the trouble
they cause is that while it seems we
must accept that each individual step
doesn't annihilate the chair clearly
enough minute removals will eventually
leave us with no chair
nothing at all in fact
but how can that be how can subtracting
zero over and over again ever give a
different result well clearly there must
be a point at which a tiny change does
make a difference now different people
might give different answers as to where
that line is but uh you know we could
just stipulate the boundaries we could
define chair in some extremely precise
way if we did that if we defined the
shape function and history that makes
something a chair so precisely that even
the smallest deviation could make or
break its status as a chair
how could we know if we'd done it right
if we
called up god and said hey hey dude
watch this okay see this chair well okay
now we're gonna remove a single atom
from it
it's no longer a chair is it
would god be like
correct you guys nailed it that is
exactly right it was a chair before and
now in my infinite wisdom i can confirm
that that single atom was exactly what
made the difference
unless there's some explanation for why
a boundary should be drawn in a precise
way instead of some other way our
stipulations are just arbitrary
ordinary objects may be
unredeemably vague
but being vague may actually be a
feature of ordinary objects for example
how many people is a crowd
10 people standing together in a huge
empty park might be more of like a group
but 10 people standing further apart in
a tiny waiting room will feel way more
crowded the fact that our terms depend
on context that they're plastic makes it
seem less and less like they're
describing things and more and more like
they're pragmatic that rather than
telling us what there is
they tell us what to expect
peter unger has pointed out that there's
at least one kind of thing that can
survive a sorority sequence without
paradox
stuff
if you innocuously remove tiny pieces
from something that is just
some stuff
you will still have some stuff after
each step until you reach a clear and
unambiguous boundary when the last piece
is removed there will no longer be any
stuff
this might show that there are composite
objects
stuff
as soon as we pretend that some stuff is
a thing though
vagueness sets in suddenly we're talking
about a thing that can lose parts but
also can't lose parts and unless
contradictions can exist
words like chair just don't really refer
to anything in the universe
so right ease sequences lead to other
problems too
like the problem of the many
if removing a tiny number of atoms from
this chair leaves me with a chair well
how many chairs are here like okay
there's there's this one but then
there's also
this one which is really similar to the
first but it doesn't have these atoms on
top of it
you know i don't have to remove atoms
for this to be a problem all i have to
do is try to define which atoms here are
part of the chair
and which aren't
at the atomic level there isn't a
definite boundary near the edge it will
be hard to tell whether a particular
molecule is
part of the moisture in the chair or
part of the ambient humidity
instead of there being a single chair
here it seems like really there are
billions and billions of candidates for
the chair
which one
is the chair
but now suppose that instead of removing
pieces like in a psorides sequence or
choosing pieces like in the problem of
the many we instead discard pieces and
replace them with new
similar pieces
this is the setup to the famous ship of
theseus paradox
suppose i buy a boat and name it theseus
over time parts of the boat wear out and
i replace them with brand new parts
after say 10 years well i might realize
that not a single part of my boat was
part of the boat on the day i bought it
do i now own a different boat have i
owned two boats but now suppose that
someone has been following me around all
these years and has been picking up each
old part i throw out and storing them
away in a warehouse
after i've replaced all the original
parts they take them and join them back
the way they were 10 years ago
which boat is theseus
both
if we conclude that ordinary objects
don't exist the problems of psorides the
many theseus over-determination and
over-counting
all evaporate
if there are only symbols and they never
compose anything then which one is the
ship of theseus is easy to answer
neither
neither are the boat and nothing ever
was the boat all that happened was that
some symbols got moved around the
symbols the scavenger has are the
symbols i possessed when i bought the
boat but there's no mystery of
persistence removing or exchanging a
piece of stuff never left me with the
same stuff
there's also no mystery as to which of
the billions of chair candidates here is
the chair and the removal of no specific
atoms will ever stop it from being a
chair because there is no chair here and
there never was there are only symbols
arranged chair-wise
the illusion that there are composites
that can survive changes in their parts
is an artifact of our minds it's a
helpful one that allows us to track
certain properties and ignore others but
when taken seriously it obviously is not
really how the universe works
and that's okay we shouldn't be
embarrassed when we talk about boats or
chairs our words for ordinary objects
really do refer to actual phenomena and
therefore are more correct than
believing that say the sun turned into a
black hole yesterday
unlike the false statement that chairs
exist there is no evidence that saying
the sun turned into a black hole
yesterday could even be incorrectly
describing because of this trenton
merricks calls the belief in ordinary
objects
false but nearly as good as true
this is all silly though right i mean of
course there are chairs if if you
believe that there are some symbols
arranged chair-wise then you admit
there's a chair because that just is
what a chair is it's not some additional
thing over and above these symbols it
just is them each is still an atom or
electron or whatever but together
they are a chair
well not so fast there chair lover what
do you mean a chair is symbols arranged
chair wise
the phrase simples arranged chair-wise
just picks out these symbols there's
nothing else for that phrase to refer to
there aren't these symbols and then also
some other symbols that are the symbols
arranged chair-wise so do you mean that
chair
is a disguised plural that it refers to
lots of things just like the phrase
these books
because these books only commits us to
the existence of this book and this book
but not an additional object that's
called a these books
likewise if chair just means this simple
and this simple and that simple well
then it points to a whole bunch of
things
and not one of them is a chair
sure
chairs exist if by chair we mean a word
for all these symbols but if by chair we
mean an actual object in the universe
there just aren't any my friend
except
maybe there is no chair over and above
the symbols but instead
something happens when an assortment of
symbols are arranged into a chair shape
each member continues to be a single
atom or whatever but collectively they
all simultaneously become one thing
a chair
okay so then either there's no chair
here just symbols or somehow a
miraculous contradiction has appeared
many things and also
one thing that despite both clearly
differing in that respect are still
identical
it looks like chairs cannot be identical
to the parts they're supposedly composed
of
but chairs also can't be different from
their composite parts because there's
nothing else there and after counting
and accounting for their parts there's
nothing left for the existence of a
chair to cause
or explain
to rescue chairs from non-existence we
need to find a way to show that a chair
is independent of its atoms and
therefore distinct from them but not so
distinct that it's impossibly over and
above them
we need to find a way to make chairs
ontologically innocent to have our cake
and not have it too
amy thomason does this in a very clever
way she points out that if i ask you uh
hey is there anything in the fridge and
you look inside and see that it's empty
and say there's nothing in it
it would be weird if i came over looked
inside myself
found a single eyelash in the corner and
said
um excuse me what is this you said there
was no thing in the fridge but there was
an eyelash
and gosh dang it the whole thing is
actually full
of air
now that would be weird because when i
asked if there was anything in the
fridge it was implied that i meant
anything
to eat
by arguing that the empty fridge is not
really empty i was using the word thing
in what thomason calls a neutral sense i
used it to mean any and all entities
that could possibly be described
but you took me to be using thing in
what she calls a sortal sense
a sortal is a term that tells us what a
thing is in a way that allows us to
count how many there are and know when
there is or isn't one
water is not a sortal if i told you
there was water in my basement and you
asked how many waters i'd have to use a
sortal to answer you for example gallons
of water
thomason argues that the neutral use of
thing
is meaningless when used to ask
questions for example if i used thing in
a neutral sense and asked how many
orange things are in this video you
would have no idea how i wanted you to
carve it all up thus there would be no
single correct answer you might say uh
one orange thing your shirt but then i
could say what no there's my left sleeve
my right sleeve the inside of the shirt
the outside of the shirt come on there's
way more than one
unless we use sortals any search for
what things there are will end in
confusion not because there are no
things but because it hasn't been made
clear what conditions to apply when
searching
for thomason this means that what we
find depends on what application
conditions we use if i ask if there's
anything here that the condition
smaller than a molecule applies to you
could note each such thing and give me
an inventory chair would not be on that
list
but if i asked you if there were any
medium-sized rigid according to human
strength things here
chair would probably go on your list and
no single atom would
if an application condition is satisfied
in the world then the thing it describes
exists
so
chairs
do exist
if the application conditions for one
thing are also sufficient for something
else then if we find the first thing we
have found the other because its
existence is entailed
analytically by the existence of the
first thing that is by meaning and logic
alone for example if i say that i live
in a house you can conclude without
looking that i live in a building
there's no paradox here i don't live in
a house and a building two distinct
things that defy the laws of physics by
being co-located
instead the conditions that apply to a
house are also sufficient for a building
so a single chair is not impossibly
identical to some collection of many nor
is it somehow over and above its parts
instead atoms arranged chairwise merely
logically entail a chair the entailment
connects things differentiated by
distinct application conditions
when we ask which one is the ship of
theseus a puzzle erupts because we're
being too neutral we need to say what we
mean by ship of theseus if we mean the
original parts then this is it do we
mean the thing registered to me by the
boat authorities well then it's this one
but which is the real one is an
incomplete pseudo question when it comes
to sobriety sequences i think we need to
just stipulate where the boundary is i
don't think there's an objective answer
provided by the universe or god as to
what exactly is and is not a chair
but that doesn't have to mean that there
aren't any chairs it can just mean that
every single collection of symbols is
its own unique object independent of our
minds and that we get to decide which to
call chairs
vagueness comes from our minds and our
language but there are no vague objects
in the universe
we don't have to believe that our
reality is simulated
but i do think we have to believe that
it's stipulated it is a reality that
contains not what intelligent machines
have decided to give us but what we have
decided
we have
there's no fact of the matter as to
whether calling this a star is the true
way to carve up this stuff
it's a pretty useful way to do it and
helpful for at least human purposes but
star is a thing we imposed on the world
as michael jubian puts it there are no
things but as a consequence there are as
many things as we like
now as for the problem of the many we
can simply just admit that there really
are billions of slightly different
chairs here some include a few boundary
atoms that others don't but since they
all act and react pretty much in unison
in our daily lives it just doesn't
matter which exact material collection
we mean when we say this chair
however
let's go back to our cranes
when we talked about holes we said that
holes might be ontologically parasitic
that their existence seems to require
the existence of something else
something that can
host the whole
perhaps our crane is holy too
not a physical thing in its own right
but a disturbance in some paper there is
no material crane here there's only some
paper arranged crane wise
but once we start entertaining that
notion we realize that nearly everything
we see and feel all ordinary objects and
even ourselves are ontological parasites
michael jubian calls our tendency to
think that what is true of a chair is
true of the material that is sharing
object fixation or property repression
object fixation is useful and nearly as
good as true but when paradoxes loom we
should remember that while chairs do
exist they are not made out of matter
and cannot be touched or felt or tasted
all i can do is taste some stuff
while it chairs
if it looks like a duck swims like a
duck and quacks like a duck then it's
not a duck but it is arranged duck wise
i think that the only concrete physical
things in our universe are symbols
or since our universe could be gunky the
material world only contains stuff and
yes this stuff is cheering but the road
paved by the idea that that makes this
stuff a chair
leads to paradox
to see how we could have made that
mistake let's remember the famous
clintonian dictum that often
it depends on what the meaning of is is
there's the is of predication which
tells us what something is like as in
this cheese
is floppy and then there's the is of
identity which tells us what is the same
as what for example
two plus two is four to believe that
chairs are made of matter to believe
that you are made of matter is to
confuse these two isses
when a collection of properties are
extremely thorough in telling us what to
expect from some stuff
we tend to just go ahead and noun them
collapse them into a single word and
believe it doesn't just describe some
stuff but refers to it i think we have
an intuitive sense of the thoroughness
of properties and this can be seen in
how we order our adjectives
big can mean many things a big diamond
and a big house are very different in
size
blue tells me a bit more about what to
expect but cheeseburger oh that's
specific so specific in fact that we
call it a noun
the increasing thoroughness may be
partly responsible for the fact that big
blue cheeseburger sounds fine but blue
big cheeseburger sounds kind of weird
when we embrace the idea that
cheeseburgers are not physical objects
but instead exist as an abstract set of
properties like juicy warm soft and so
on the specter of ontological paradox
dissipates
you and i are not physical objects
either
micheline is a bunch of different
properties and most of them are very
vague they include things like knowing
who kevin is
being more or less a certain height
having a roughly continuous relationship
with the stuff that was micheline
yesterday
now some of what it means to michael
does concern composition like the fact
that i will still exist even if i shave
off the stuff i call my beard if i
shaved off my beard
there would still be some stuff
michaelin but it would be different
stuff than it was before
we are able to lose parts and change and
grow because we are not made of matter
we are hosted by matter
as alan watts would say the universe
doesn't contain people
the universe
peoples
chairs and tables and rocks and buckets
and people
are not made of atoms
they are performed by atoms
we are disturbances in stuff and none of
it is us
this stuff right here is not me it's
just
me
we are not the universe seeing itself
we are the seeing
i am not a thing that dies and becomes
scattered
i am death and i am the scattering
and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
as always links to read and learn more
can be found down in the description
below there's also a link down there to
subscribe to the curiosity box if you
subscribe now this will be your first
box but remember use code bogo and we'll
send you our summer box as well
completely free
give your brain a treat
support vsauce support alzheimer's
research and creators everywhere by
joining today
i'll see you there
and as always
thanks for watching
you